pour les besoins d'une enquête la stèle
tombale a été retirée de l'église en
début d'après midi par un marbrier
mandaté 24 heures après les faits l'
enquête se poursuit pour comprendre ce
qu'il s'est passé comment ce retraité de
74 ans a pu se retrouver écrasé par
cette stèle ce monument se trouvaient
dans l'église depuis pratiquement deux
ans un souhait d'une association de
valorisation de l'archéologie et de
l'histoire de lure la société
d'archéologie nous a demandé de la deûle
à poser à l'église donc nous ville de
lure on a accédé à leurs demandes tout
en leur demandant quelques quelques
garanties le pauvre c'est-à-dire passer
par un parent à marbrier pour faire ce
travail quoi
l'homme est décédé de ses blessures à
l'hôpital de besançon un décès qui a
requalifié l'enquète en enquête pour
homicide involontaire avec plusieurs
points à vérifier les éléments d'enquêté
vont devoir tout d'abord s'intéresser à
un autre victime
quelles étaient les raisons de sa
présence à ce moment précis dans dans
l'église
et puis est-ce qu'il a eu effectivement
un comportement particulier qui a fait
chuter la stèle
et puis en second lieu une expertise
bien entendu est en cours sur la stèle
ses fixations
ce fait a profondément choqué les
habitants de lure l'homme était connu
dans la ville alors les prochaines
semaines devraient nous apporter des
éléments de réponse pour comprendre ce
qu'il s'est passé